hey 42 here scotland a land where tartan
is the height of fashion people throw
tree trunks for fun
and ground up sheeps in it are
considered a national delicacy
oh and they also call lakes locks
and when it comes to locks scotland has
a lot of them
so many that an exact count has never
been made
though it's estimated there are more
than 30 000 in total ranging from
pint-sized lock-hands to mighty biamoffs
like loch lomond
so it probably shouldn't come as any
surprise that a country containing so
many vast foreboding bodies of water is
rich with tales of water-dwelling
monsters
take the kelpie for example a
shape-shifting horse-like creature that
entices unsuspecting victims to climb
onto its back before charging them into
the watery depths and drowning them
or the blue men of minch evil merman who
dwell in underwater caves waiting to
capsize passing boats
but of course one scottish folk tale
reigns supreme i am of course talking
about the loch ness monster a creature
that has become as synonymous with
scotland as bagpipes haggis and kilts
so how exactly did the loch ness monster
become the grand daddy champion of
scottish folklore
well all it took was a hippopotamus
a surgeon and a toy submarine
but more on that later
as far as hiding places go a monster
could do much worse than loch ness for a
start not only is the water almost
completely black due to the high levels
of peat it's also pretty bloody deep
so deep in fact that if you were to
place the great pyramid of giza at
deluxe deepest point and have the statue
of liberty climb on top
her torch would only just break the
surface
and if you don't think that's impressive
enough
loch ness holds about 7.5 million cubic
kilometers of water
which is more than all of the lakes in
england and wales combined
that's a lot of water for a secretive
beastie to hide out in
for the most part sightings of nessie
started relatively recently towards the
end of the 19th century
but some people believe the evidence
goes back much further than that all the
way to depicts
a confederation of tribes who inhabited
much of scotland during the early middle
ages
although dismissed by the romans as
savages the pics were actually rather
cultured and when they weren't engaging
in the occasional barbaric scuffle they
enjoyed nothing more than making pretty
carvings of the flowers and animals that
surrounded them one of these carvings
which has come to be known as the
pictish beast appears to depict some
kind of aquatic creature but what
exactly
some have suggested it's a porpoise or a
dolphin
maybe even a swimming elephant but with
its elongated neck and what appears to
be flippers
you have to admit it bears more than a
passing resemblance to a certain
lock-dwelling creature
of course it's probably just a
coincidence but
if it is
it's a weird one
and that isn't the only evidence of an
unidentified aquatic creature living
near loch ness in the middle ages a
biography of saint columba written in
565 a.d
speaks of an incident in which the
saints encountered a mysterious water
beast that had recently killed a local
villager
it should be noted that this incident
took place in the river ness and not the
lock itself
but river ness monster doesn't quite
have the same ring to it does it
in spite of the picked mysterious
carvings and saint columbus heroics at
the river ness
it wasn't until a sighting in 1933 that
most people really started entertaining
the idea that there could be a monster
living in that yonder luck
and
oddly enough this sighting actually took
place on land
as george spicer and his wife drove by
the luck one evening they were startled
by what they described as most
extraordinary form of animal
walking across the road in front of them
the creature was said to have a large
body and a long wavy neck as they drove
closer george noted that it carried in
its mouth what appeared to be the
carcass of a lamb
after a report of the sighting was
published in the press people began
descending on the lock hoping to see the
monster for themselves
sightings of the beast began to stack up
and pretty soon messi fever had gripped
the nation
desperate to bag the scoop of the
century the daily mail newspaper
recruited a renowned big game hunter
with the exceptional name of marmaduke
weverell to travel to loch ness and
track down this elusive beast
and at first it appeared wetherwell was
about to do just that after only a few
days of monster hunting he found unusual
footprints embedded within the banks of
the log he declared that they belonged
to a very powerful soft-footed animal
about 20 feet long
he made casts of the prince and sent
them to the natural history museum to be
identified
but when the museum announced their
verdict
the news wasn't good the footprint
didn't belong to a loch ness monster but
to an altogether more common beast a
hippopotamus
of course whilst hippos are fairly
common you don't tend to find many of
them in scotland
so what was this particular specimen
doing so far from home
unfortunately the answer isn't quite as
exciting as you might think and is
actually kind of grim
the prince had been made using a hippo
foot ashtray that's quite literally a
hippo's severed foot with an ashtray
mounted on top
not the kind of thing i imagine would
fly off the shelves today but back then
they were all the rage
weverall's reputation was left in
tatters
it's unclear whether or not he planted
the footprints himself or if he'd fallen
foul of a prank
but neither option left him looking all
that good
either way the nessie bubble had burst
and it was going to take something
incredible to reignite public enthusiasm
you know something like someone taking
an actual photograph of a monster in
loch ness
and as it happens that's exactly what
happened next
the following year a surgeon by the name
of robert kenneth wilson was standing by
the luck thinking about whatever it is
surgeons think about on their days off
when he spotted a
type creature sticking its head out of
the water
fortunately wilson had his camera at the
ready
the image wilson captured would come to
be known as the surgeon's photograph and
it's probably the most famous nessie
photo in existence
although lacking in detail by today's
standards
many were convinced of its authenticity
after all this was a time before
photoshop and cgi
a time when people truly believed that
the cameras never lied for many the
surgeon's photograph provided
irrefutable proof that there really was
a monster living in loch ness now that
it appeared there might be some truth
behind the many sightings that had been
reported
some began to speculate as to what kind
of animal the loch ness monster might be
the most prominent explanation was that
nessie was descended from a lineage of
plesiosaurs that somehow survived the kt
extinction event that wiped out the
dinosaurs 66 million years ago and
adapted to life in bonnie scotland
the idea that something fought to have
been extinct for millions of years might
be discovered alive and kicking today
might seem ludicrous
but it has actually happened before
scientists only knew of the existence of
coelacanths a type of fish they presumed
had gone extinct during the cretaceous
period free fossils up to 410 million
years old
and then
someone found one swimming off the coast
of africa in 1938
so with that in mind could a plesiosaur
really be lurking in loch ness
well the honest slightly boring answer
is no
probably not
for a long time scientists assumed
plesiosaurs could never have survived in
loch ness because it was believed they
were cold-blooded and therefore needed
relatively warm water to thrive
scottish locks have a lot of things
going for them but paddling temperatures
isn't one of them
but recent research suggests plesiosaurs
may well actually have been
warm-blooded blowing that particular
argument out of the freezing cold
scottish lock water
sadly that doesn't make the pleciosaur
theory any more likely
after all to have survived the last 66
million years
a whole colony of those beasts would
need to be down there
not only would it be pretty difficult
for a large number of giant reptiles to
hide in loch ness without modern
technology being able to locate them
we'd also expect to find plenty of
plesiosaur bones littering deluxe depths
and
we haven't
the truth is beyond a few random
sightings over the years there is
precisely zero evidence that there's
anything in loch ness other than fish
and a few thousand empty bottles of iron
blue
but if not a plesiosaur then what
exactly did wilson take a photo of
well in 1994 60 years after the
photograph was taken two gentlemen named
david martin and alastair boyd
made it to their mission to find out
exactly that
and what they discovered was a lot
stranger than you might have imagined
the two men were members of a research
team based in loch ness
and they were keen to prove once and for
all whether the surgeon's photo was
authentic
boyd was further buoyed
see what i did there
by his own sighting of nessie some years
earlier and he was desperate to know for
certain if wilson really had
photographed a lock's resident monster
the pair had recently come into
possession of a newspaper article from
in which it was alleged the photo had
been the result of an elaborate hoax for
whatever reason the article hadn't
received much attention at the time of
its publication
but martin and boyd felt it warranted
further investigation
and so began decades of dedicated
research
with the pair risking life and limb to
uncover the truth
actually that's not true at all they
simply followed some basic leads that
led them to an elderly scottish man
named christian sperling
when they asked sperling if he knew
anything about the photograph without
hesitation he told them the alleged
monster the most treasured nessie photo
in scotland
was nothing more than a bit of wood
mounted on top of a toy submarine
and how did sperling come by this
startling information
simple
he'd built that model himself at the
request of his stepfather
who was none other than our old friend
marmaduke weverell
you see weverall had been so embarrassed
by the hippo print fiasco and his
treatment at the hands of the daily mail
that he'd set out to exact his revenge
by fooling the press into believing
there really was a loch ness monster
after sperling had finished building his
model his father had taken it to loch
ness where he'd enlisted the help of his
other son ian weverell
once they'd made sure nobody else was
around the conspiracy snapped a few
photographs of sperling's creation
bobbing around in the water
they gave the results to their friend
the surgeon robert wilson because
weverall felt wilson's reputable
profession meant there was less chance
of the photographs authenticity being
brought into question
the prank was far more successful than
any of them could ever have hoped the
press took the bait and
the rest is history
in more recent times robotic
submersibles
sonar equipment and drones have all been
used in an attempt to find nessie but as
yet nobody's been able to provide any
solid evidence of her existence
in 2019 researchers attempted to catalog
all living species within the lock by
extracting dna from the water
their results showed no evidence of
anything out of the ordinary
with only a giant eel being put forward
as a possible explanation for the many
sightings over the years despite a lack
of hard evidence loch ness continues to
attract millions of people every year he
will arrive from all corners of the
globe hoping to catch a glimpse of the
enigmatic creature and although nessie
might not make an appearance
the dark and mysterious waters of loch
ness continue to enchant and captivate
people
just the way they did
thousands of years ago
thanks for watching
good news you can now pre-order my new
book bread and circuses what did the
romans ever do for us it's a wild and
witty journey for a thousand years of
unexpected roman history
told in a refreshing way and packed full
of incredible and unbelievable stories
copies are selling out fast so pre-order
yours today to lock it in thank you